5 4 3 2 1.
Now we're live yes.
Hello.
What's happenin.
Not much I'm excited to be here.
I'm excited to have you here.
Your father speaks very highly of you.
That's good.
What is it like to have Jordan Peterson
as a dad.
Is it weird you have to check yourself
constantly and make sure you're on.
Your unsteady ground and I say anything
ridiculous.
No not at all.
Not at all.
I didn't realize it was weird until I
went away to university and then kind
of.
So I just I was away for a while and
then when I came back to the house
especially because the house is full of
like paintings and masks and statues and
like 32 different paint colors and I
came back and was like oh maybe he's a
bit eccentric.
Now he's definitely IG centric.
We were talking off air about what it
was like to watch your dad become famous
and become famous and in his 50s right.
Like yeah I hope fifty four fifty five.
That's when he became famous before that
relatively unknown respected professor.
One issue with this one transgender Bill
the the preferred pronouns bill and then
boom.
Off to the races.
Yeah strange it was.
Yeah it was super weird especially how
the media was portraying him and how
what was actually happening at the
events wasn't what was being portrayed
in the media.
So that was weird to watch and then
people recognizing him on the street is
strange.
Yes.
When you say what what happened in real
life was not was what was being
portrayed like what was different.
Mostly what he was saying.
So most of what he said is on film
anyway so you can go to YouTube and see
what he's been saying like not there's
not like some secret that's going
around.
But what's been portrayed has been so
much more negative than what he's
actually said or they'll take like sound
bites and just weave a story that isn't
quite true.
Which I didn't read for some reason I
know it looks silly but for some reason
I just thought that what the media was
portraying was honest always.
Yeah yeah me too.
Yeah yeah.
And it's not.
Well the writers you know and what's
there's real issue today that that issue
I've talked about this before but the
issue is clicks Yeah.
It's not just about what's the facts of
the story.
It's about these publications are
struggling to stay alive.
And one of the only ways that they can
get people to click on stories is
salacious headlines real make things
really click baby.
And that's what they focus on and they
focus on negative aspects that are going
to get people riled up.
They have to have an angle.
And I've talked to people who are
writers who will write something and
then I'll talk to them and I'll say Hey
man this is not what we talked about or
what happened.
And they said I'm going to be honest
with you.
I didn't even write that the headline
was completely written by the editor.
So the editor came and changed it all up
changed this switch put some dot dot dot
side of things you know.
So cut off sentences so that they seemed
more you know just more controversial
than they really are because they didn't
allow the counterpoint of you know
sometimes you say something and they say
or it could be this or the or it could
be this part is cut out.
You know they do things like that just
to stay alive because I think when you I
mean really big publications whether
it's the New York Times or whether you
know the Boston Globe like big
publications are struggling for their
life right now because people who want
to buy newspapers anymore and you know
and getting people to read things online
is very difficult and you have to you
have to do something salacious.
You have to do something that's enticing
for them to click on it.
Yeah.
Gasp and I wouldn't you say that's just
driving them down.
Yeah yeah.
Yeah they're fucked.
It's a bad place to be.
Yeah.
And I think it's you know it opens up
the door for alternative media.
But some of those alternative media
sources don't have journalistic
integrity either.
So that it becomes a real issue.
You know that's that's a problem with
lot of online news shows.
It's like they take a very obvious
editorial spin as well on the news.
And if you just read or watch their show
you would go oh well it's this way
because these guys are saying it's this
way.
But it might not be that way.
There's no real objective source is very
hard to find a good objective source.
I mean sometimes I count on the New York
Times but there's been some things that
I've read from The New York Times that I
know or not.
I think they had a terrible article
about Dad.
Oh yeah.
Like June or something.
Yeah.
He didn't make it any easier on himself
by using that forced monogamy or term no
enforced monogamy argument or term
because I don't I don't even with the
when you understand it as a
psychological concept that it is a
culturally enforced idea.
I still don't think that applies to in
cells.
I don't I just don't you know only it
makes any difference at all and he and I
discussed it on the podcast you're not
just because you say it's a good idea
and the culture agrees it's a good idea
for people to be monogamous I don't
necessarily think that that is going to
help these guys at all.
I don't think we know what's going to
help those guys.
Yeah well obviously they're all
individuals and their situations vary
but when we're talking about people like
what the fuck are they talking about.
There was a quote in The New York Times
where this woman was asking him what to
do about these in cells which are
involuntary celibate and one of them had
driven a car into a crowd of people and
killed a bunch of people because he was
frustrated because he couldn't find a
mate.
And your dad suggested that
if culturally enforced monogamy would be
perhaps a solution for that and then a
bunch of you went crazy saying that like
women.
He's saying that women should sacrifice
themselves fuck these guys that they
don't drive cars in the crowds.
Yes.
Yeah.
It was the whole everybody made a
mistake.
Yeah.
I don't see there's an answer for those
guys.
I really don't.
But now with that but that is that those
kind of articles are like the editorial
articles and opinion articles.
It's really it's a different thing than
reporting on the news right.
Yeah I thought I thought so honesty was
always a big thing in our house and was
like Don't lie because if you lie
eventually the lie will surface and will
be so much bigger than the how you get
from telling the truth.
So I kind of just assumed that the media
did that.
Yeah the world just worked like that.
Yeah no.
Now I know that now.
Yeah
.
So you and your dad a bolt on this wacky
diet you're both on this wacky carnivore
diet and this is probably one of the
most controversial things in our
relationship in relation to food today.
When.
When people discuss diets you know
there's a lot of people that are
vegetarian or vegan or try and ketogenic
diet or paleo but when you say carnivore
that is one of the ones where people
just universally seem to like step back
roll their eyes.
Most people don't think it's a good
idea.
They don't even know why they don't
think it's a good idea.
And then you tell them about people like
you or my friend Chris Bell who has
similar autoimmune issues and he's had
hip to hip replacements.
He's only 36 now and I think he had both
of them done by the time he was 30
right.
Pretty sure because he's had them for
quite a few years you know massive joint
pain of all sorts of issue and you when
did you got a hip replacement.
How old were you.
Seventeen and an ankle replacement.
Seventeen.
Days is a rough year.
That's crazy.
What do you so your whole life.
You've had arthritis issues or.
Yeah.
So I started walking kind of funny when
I was two.
According to my mom and she brought me
to the doctor and they said just having
growing pains or something when I was 7
I was diagnosed with juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis and I had like 37 joints
affected.
And then I was put on immunosuppressants
in Grade 4.
So I was actually the first kid in
Canada to be put on this biologic called
Enbrel goes on and roll and methotrexate
for ever like leading up to the hip an
ankle replacement and they did help
reduce some of the pain but I still
ended up with no cartilage in my joint
and hip my hip and ankle when I was 17
and this is just from the effects of
arthritis and the inflammation swelling
and just to the cartilage.
So I wasn't even particularly swollen I
didn't have a very inflammatory visually
inflammatory arthritis so my
rheumatologist who had been at Sick Kids
for 20 years said that I had the worst
arthritis she'd ever seen.
So it was very severe.
It wasn't particularly like swollen my
joints just disintegrated
Wow.
Mm hmm.
What do they think causes something like
this.
They didn't know.
So it was.
Eventually after the hip and ankle
replacement the diagnosis was changed to
juvenile idiopathic arthritis.
So it was literally like we don't know
well.
And
how did you go from these medications
pharmaceutical medications to getting
into this carnivore diet thing.
What was this.
This path.
Well OK I'll give you a background of
the path.
We were very like science oriented
especially dad.
So even though mom kind of wanted to
delve into diet and was like we should
go sugar free or stop eating you know
whatever make sure you'd whole grains
like all that stuff we never gave diet.
A chance because there was no scientific
evidence for it.
So I basically got sicker and sicker and
sicker and I ended up by the time I got
to university I ended up with arthritis
I was severely depressed.
I was on anti-depressants as well.
I had idiopathic hyper Sonia I was
sleeping about 18 hours a day.
My whole body was itchy all the time.
That started when I was about 14
and so that was when I started
university and then my diet just got
disastrous in university and I was like
drinking all the time and eating like
pizza and beer.
And I gained like 30 pounds in the first
year.
And ginger ale a lot of ginger ale.
Anyway I gained about 30 pounds in the
first year.
My mental health declined even further.
And I didn't really know what was going
on.
And then I started getting skin issues
so I started getting rashes cystic acne
and I was like OK I can deal with like
four really awful health problems but I
can't deal with things affecting my skin
on top of that.
There's too many things.
I went to dermatologists and they
basically told me I was anxious and like
causing these rashes by itching so that
was the dermatologists opinion which is
very unhelpful.
Anyway I spent a lot of time.
I was eventually prescribed Adderall for
the hyper sommelier.
So I spent all my time googling reading
papers trying to get a background on
skin disorders.
And eventually I came across this Celiac
Disease rash online and that's what I
had it looked exactly the same.
So I cut out gluten.
I read a whole bunch about the effects
of gluten on the guide and thought oh
there's actually some evidence that
gluten isn't good for people why aren't
people being told this like why didn't
my doctor test me for celiac disease
because Celiac Disease couples with
autoimmune disorders all the time like
they test type 1 kids for celiac
disease.
But for some reason they don't test kids
with arthritis for celiac disease.
So kind of gluten and that kind of
helped maybe like 20 percent but it was
hard to tell because it was the summer
was like maybe I'm just feeling better
from the summer.
My rash kind of went down but it was
still there and then.
So September 2015 my mom dragged me to a
natural path and they gave me the sheet
of foods like try this elimination diet.
And I looked at the sheet and thought
this doesn't make any sense like why can
I eat lemons and not oranges and why are
almonds on there but other nuts are off.
So I cut.
So I thought OK I'm going to do an
elimination diet which I didn't believe
in at all.
I'll cut down to what I considered safe
foods.
And I had no idea what I was doing.
So I just thought OK vegetables are
pretty safe I'll get rid of nightshade
because people talk about them being bad
like cheese was nitrates next to AIDS
like tomatoes eggplant those kind of
foods for some reason there.
I just knew that they were then referred
to as nitrates.
I feel like literally everybody has
heard them referred to as Nightshade.
No.
Have you heard them.
I've heard the term but not.
I couldn't tell you what it was.
I wouldn't have been able to say it as
an eggplant so I think maybe it's just
kids don't make it to the end.
I don't think so.
No.
Oh okay.
Well at the YouTube comments.
Decide.
Don't let them decide okay.
It's like calling demons for help too
good.
Anyway I cut down so I was eating mostly
like green vegetables.
I was still eating rice at that point
because I thought everybody eats rice
rice is safe and meat but I cut out like
dairy.
Most grains soy sugar processed foods
and then in the next month my joints got
way better and my skin healed and my
skin never healed like for a couple of
years.
I'd always have these flare ups and
never went away.
And that was just on a like relatively
low carb diet just like just less.
I don't know.
I was still eating rice right.
But it was still mostly meat and
vegetables and I thought OK maybe
there's something to this.
And then I made almond flour gluten free
sugar free dairy free almond flour
banana muffins and I ate a bunch of
those one night and I woke up and the
next day my wrists were sore and I
thought
OK maybe that's weird.
And then I had a bunch more than muffins
because the muffins were good and and
then I went away to college that weekend
and I couldn't walk because of my knees
and I never had flare ups that badly
like I used to get my shoulder was
always sore when I slept so I took
Tylenol three at night for sleeping and
my wrists were stiff but I never had
like a flare up like I couldn't walk.
So that was that weekend.
So then I went back to the diet and got
really strict with it and then things
were better like my skin was better I I
lost.
This was weird.
I lost five pounds which wasn't a lot
but I went down three pant sizes so it
was all bloating that I didn't realize
was bloating because it never
fluctuated.
So that was the first month and then
2015 and then I started trying to
reintroduce foods because I was having
cravings and I missed going out to eat
with my friends and everything.
So I tried to read the first thing I
tried to reintroduce was sour patch
Candy because I was having really
intense sugar look at me like that I was
having really intense sugar cravings and
I looked at the packet and I thought OK
no one's allergic to sugar there's no
dairy there's no gluten there's no soy.
This will be fine.
And I really wanted to eat them and I
had those and the next day my whole body
was itchy again and it was like like
mosquito bites everywhere itchy.
So I thought OK maybe maybe that was a
bad idea.
So I waited a couple of weeks and I
tried to reintroduce almond butter
organic almond butter because I wanted
something fast protein fast and then I
had a slight abdominal cramping diarrhea
then this itch came back to Jesus
Christ.
Yeah.
So for the next year
well I'll slow down.
We've got some time.
That was that was the almond butter.
So then I waited a while and I felt
pretty good.
This was November 2015.
And then I started feeling really good
and I went off of my anti-depressants
and I had been taking anti-depressants
since I was in grade 5 a really high
dose of an SSRI which had been very
helpful.
But do you wean yourself off and do it
under a doctor's supervision.
No I didn't.
You didn't right.
I weaned myself down so I went down to
half and then I went to a quarter and
then I went to an eighth and then I
stopped taking how long to wait time.
It was nothing really.
Over two weeks it was two weeks.
Yeah.
I didn't have withdrawal symptoms like I
think maybe I was lucky that way.
And so you died at this point was so at
that point I was eating rice
occasionally but it was mostly like
broccoli salad chicken beef fish you
know olive oil apple cider vinegar salt
pepper
at that point I was also eating pears
and apples.
So it was kind of like paleo kind of
very restricted paleo dairy free.
And so you're feeling good you're off
your medication your joints feel better.
No more rashes no more rashes Yeah.
So everything seems to be improving.
I was shocked when the depression lifted
because I thought that runs in my family
that's familial we have some sort of
brain chemistry problem that can't
possibly be diet.
I thought I thought the skin maybe that
was diet because this gluten link and
then maybe because of the celiac gene
that I got tested for maybe the
arthritis was part of that but I never
thought mood was associated with it.
So that was a surprise in November.
Anyway I went off of the
anti-depressants and then I'm about a
month later I tried to reintroduce soy
and this is when things started getting
really weird that year.
So I was having are you reintroducing
things if you're having all these
positive benefits.
I was having cravings like crazy and I
would miss eating out and I thought
there were probably like four or five
foods I was really sensitive to and if I
could just figure out what they were I
could eat pretty normally.
I didn't realize like I didn't know what
was going on.
If I had known I would have done it much
different.
But I tried to reintroduce soy because
at that point I still thought soy was a
health food.
So I ate a huge meal of like at a mommy
beans and bean sprouts and miso soup
that I made myself.
So it was gluten free and soy sauce and
tofu.
I literally aid soy in every form and I
had the same kind of reaction with
almond butter.
I had immediately got bloated I had
diarrhea like within maybe 20 30 minutes
of eating it.
And I thought OK that's OK I guess I
can't eat soy.
And then about four hours later my legs
got edgy and then my whole body got
itchy and I was like OK that sucks I'm
clearly I'm reacting to soy.
And then the next morning the depression
came back and it came back like that was
the worst depressive experience I've
ever had.
I was medication free and it came back
in the morning and I got in the shower
and I just like I bawled in the shower
and thought how could I be so naive to
think that my horrible auto immune
disorder and the depression and
everything was caused by food like what
an idiotic thing to think how could I be
that hopeful and then I had to remind
myself OK.
No you ate a whole bunch of this food
then you had this like digestive
distress then you got itchy.
And now the depression is back.
There's clearly a pattern here.
It was hard to think like that when I
got that depressed so that day was like
I spent a lot of that day crying.
Then the next day got worse.
And this is this is when it gets weird.
So that night I went over to my parents
and I was just like I don't know what's
going on right.
And they're like Well don't take a car
back to your apartment.
I said I don't think I can drive like I
can't I just can't think I don't know
what's going on.
So my brother drove me home and I was
like on the verge of having a panic
attack for no reason writers just like
my heart rate was increasing I was
trying to find my keys and I turned
around to look at my brother in the car
and
his head was a like a kind of a demon.
This
I know how this sounds but he had like a
demon head for about a second and a half
and he looked at me and then he turned
and then it was my brother again.
So standing is what your.
For like a Yeah about a second and a
half the hallucinations that year yes.
Before that.
No.
That year.
Yeah.
After this I'll get into.
So you eat soy and started tripping.
Yeah.
Two days later.
I know how it sounds.
That's how it sounded to me too.
Have you found comparable stories.
So.
So obviously I did as much research as I
could possibly do to soy no to gluten.
To people who are schizophrenic from
gluten.
Yeah there are people with celiac
disease who have schizophrenia induced
by gluten.
So I found that but I didn't find
anything for other foods.
But the skills of schizophrenia include
hallucinations rarely visual.
But I did find a case study of a woman
who was seeing demons from her Celiac
Disease gluten.
Now when you say you looked over and you
saw your brother and his head was a
demon had like describe it like no I
found them.
No it was like eat.
You know when it's really dark in a
room.
And I don't know if you've experienced
this but it's really dark in the room.
And then you kind of kind of see things
in the dark.
Mm hmm.
It was more like that.
It was dark at night and it was like I
was so anxious so distraught.
You're a mess and maybe you just caused
yourself to while something idea okay.
Yeah I mean I saw it like I can remember
what it looks like but it wasn't a vivid
demon or something.
It was like but it was there okay.
So you're freaking out.
I'm so I'm freaking out so I'm like OK
that's not good.
I find my keys and I go upstairs and
then I went into my bedroom and shut the
blinds turned on all the lights.
And then like smoked as much weed as I
could possibly smoke to try and calm
myself down and then hid under the
blankets all night.
I would think that would be the worst
thing to do.
A demon.
You'd think that but then if you I've
had that comment before but enough and
it calm me down.
Okay.
So then I spent the next couple of weeks
basically stoned because I didn't know
when it was going to end.
I didn't know what was going on and I
couldn't find anybody on the internet
who had had the same experience as me
and then about two and a half weeks
later it started going away.
And so you say it.
You mean the depression.
Depression the arthritis.
It wasn't that just the depression that
came that's just just the words I know I
didn't go back.
I mean I need soy again but I went back
to the initial diet.
I was eating so essentially just this
one meal this one great meal of soy
threw you off for a couple of weeks
right.
Yeah like almost for like three weeks
but after two weeks it started getting
better.
But the symptoms were like So that's
deplorable the itching started I had
bloating and then the depression came
back.
And then about a week later my skin
started breaking out.
And then maybe ten days later my
arthritis came back.
So I wrote all my symptoms down every
day because I was going crazy and I
didn't know what was going on and I
wanted to write it down to see what was
going on.
OK.
So then I started lifting and I started
feeling better again and I was like OK
thank God that's over and then waited
while things were good again.
My symptoms went away.
And then over the next year I tried to
reintroduce foods over and over and over
again and I was making it like I tried
whey protein powder and that didn't
help.
Nothing ever got to as bad as that soy
experience but I had a number of other
experiences where it was the worst
depression I've ever experienced and it
was on the verge of seeing like I don't
know seeing faces and things.
So you're having all these health
issues.
How do you get to the carnivore diet.
So I decide about a year later I decide
hey maybe I don't want to keep cycling
in and out of a horrible autoimmune
mental problems maybe I'll just stick
with the original diet.
Mm hmm.
And then I got pregnant and so then my
auto immune symptoms flared again during
the pregnancy.
Yeah like right away as soon as I found
out I was pregnant it was like before I
found out I was pregnant that my
autoimmune symptoms came back so my legs
were itchy again.
I was.
My joints were stiff my skin was
breaking out my anxiety was back and it
was hard to tell Well what part of this
is pregnancy and what part of this is an
autoimmune disorder.
So throughout my pregnancy I cut down on
all the carbs I was eating so I cut out
fruit and cut out sweet potatoes I went
down to meat and greens and I think dad
was on here one time and he was on a
meat and greens diet.
So that was doing that part.
So we're both on the meat and greens
diet mostly because we didn't realize
you didn't need Greens to survive so we
were eating meat greens and then I have
to say mostly because we realize you
didn't well means we didn't love.
We didn't realize meat only wasn't
organized.
Yeah.
We hadn't realized that we didn't know
that.
So as meat and salad it was very simple
salad with like olive oil apple cider
vinegar salt pepper cucumbers lettuces
spinach pretty simple salad.
And then meat and fish so we did that
for about a year and then I had my
daughter and then I didn't get better.
So then I found out OK.
So these symptoms aren't really
pregnancy related it's just me now and
for some reason I've lost the tolerance
to these foods I used to be able to eat
and and you're just eating salad and
meat.
Yeah and I'm still having autoimmune so
now it's symptoms that you used to have
not in your reading.
Not reason not nearly as bad not nearly
as bad like my fatigue wasn't back.
My anxiety was manageable without
medication.
But you hadn't achieved the levels of.
I didn't know that you had.
Yeah.
You were eliminating things from your
diet earlier.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Like I reached a really good point and
then I got pregnant and I couldn't reach
that point again.
So then this is 2017 so it's like
November and I'm getting really
frustrated about being itchy.
I'm just randomly itchy again and
randomly early read about eating meat
and veg just means salad.
Yeah.
And I thought OK maybe I just have an
autoimmune disorder and I can't control
it with diet anymore.
Maybe this maybe I'm just stuck like
this.
And so I googled like out of
desperation.
I think I Googled allergic to everything
food wise something like that into
google and I found the story about
Charlene Anderson who's been mentioned a
couple of times and she'd been diagnosed
with Lyme disease and has been eating
nothing but like red meat for 18 years.
And there are pictures of her family
online and I thought OK I know I'm not.
I think I Googled allergic to everything
except meat.
So I found her then I found that Shawn
Baker episode you did.
And he'd been doing it for two years and
I think that night I thought Screw it.
I literally have nothing to lose here.
I'm only cutting out salad so that's
when I switched over.
That was December and then I switched
over and the itching got better pretty
quickly like within the first couple of
days.
But then my digestion just got totally
screwed up.
So like bloating and diarrhea every time
I eat and after about a week I thought
Kay this is a bad idea obviously
diarrhea every time you eat meat just
meat just name and salt roast.
Yeah.
So I thought this is a bad idea.
Obviously this isn't working my body
doesn't like it.
So I reintroduced salad again.
It was literally lettuce apple cider
vinegar olive oil and salt and pepper.
That's what I reintroduced.
And I woke up the next day and the itch
was back in my joints were stiff and I
thought OK if I have to choose between
itching and arthritis or diarrhea I'm
going to choose the diarrhea.
I was in a rough place.
Mm hmm yes.
So I stuck it out and at six weeks of
just doing this my diet the bloating
went away the diarrhea went away and
everything started to improve.
So that was mid-January but I was still
pretty skeptical because I thought I
thought maybe the reason the carnivore
diet worked for people was because they
just accidentally cut out everything
that wasn't working for them.
Processed foods sugar grains all that.
So I tried to reintroduce all lives like
organic olives and all of oil.
That was February and then I had this
itching came back with the depression
and my skin broke out and it was minor
in comparison to like soy.
So you think essentially to give us the
Cliff Notes you're allergic to
everything Yeah
that's fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
But then here's the thing.
I started this blog so the blogs don't
eat that.
I started this blog because I thought if
for some reason there's someone else out
there like me and they're Googling these
things it'd be nice for them to know
that they're not alone right.
And I've found other people like this
who are equally as sensitive I'm sure.
I mean look if you exist there's
probably quite a few people that have
that issue.
And since it makes sense that we all
have different tolerances and we all
have different allergies some people are
allergic to cats some people have no
problem with peanuts.
Some people eat a brazil nut and they
die just yet.
We know this.
So the idea this is one of the problems
with diet is that people want to think
that a diet that works for them works
for everybody and it doesn't work that
way.
And thing think people want you to
follow their diet no matter what it is
whether it's vegan or paleo.
People are very ideological with that.
They would love you for you to do
exactly what they're doing.
So to reinforce what they're doing is
correct.
There's a lot of pushback against this
carnivore diet idea but I don't I I
don't think it's outside the realm of
possibility that someone like you might
actually really be allergic to
everything.
Yeah I mean I was like very sick and
from coming from that place to now I can
see how sick I was and it was like I was
dying.
You have a bunch of medication just
trying to do anything with probiotics.
Yeah.
I can't tolerate probiotics you can't
tolerate them.
No.
So the original idea was heal my God
repopulate with bacteria that maybe I'm
missing and then maybe incorporate more
foods right.
So what happened when I tried to do the
same autoimmune flare up.
OK but this is the same autumn immune
flare up that you got when you eat
salad.
No not quite not quite as bad not.
It was different.
It was like with salad there's more of
the arthritis.
Mm hmm.
And like body pain and then with
probiotics would you get mood issues.
So like really volatile.
And itchy.
Right.
So I still got the itch.
Yeah.
So I think it was I probably had leaky
got into the program just going
everywhere.
One of things your dad brought up to me
when he was here was the most fires.
Yeah yeah.
And then I started reading up on it
after he discussed it with me.
And it's something that I never even
considered before.
But fast rising yeast and all these
different impulsive fires that they put
in bread and wine and various foods.
Mm hmm.
They're terrible for you.
Oh my God yeah.
Terrible for your stomach in there.
They're so prevalent.
They're everywhere.
Yeah.
Soy less often.
Yes.
It's in everything it's in everything.
And then I started really paying
attention to it.
I've read several articles on it.
And then a couple of studies.
It's it's crazy how this is something
that's never even discussed and it has
all sorts of negative effects on your
gut and your gut lining.
It's awful.
Yeah.
Combining that and then it looks like
grains aren't so good for people.
Combining that in grains.
It's no wonder people are ill.
Some people yes.
Some people most people though feel look
like obesity or I wouldn't go most I
would say some let's say most people are
sedentary.
That's one of the primary Yeah.
But I don't think that's the issue.
I mean.
I mean OK.
Say I mean I guess I'm not a great
example but I mean people start gaining
weight if they're lucky when they're
middle aged if they're unlucky when
they're around 25 and they start gaining
weight.
I don't think it's from lack of exercise
I think it's from diet and I think
diners let's do it.
Yeah for sure.
But it's also lack of exercise.
I don't know.
I'm not convinced because people who've
gone onto this carnivore diet especially
lose that weight.
But there's a lot of people out there
that are not overweight that don't
follow the carnivore diet so how to
explain that.
Well I'd like to see anybody above the
age of 50 know on a standard standard
American diet award is a standard
American diet.
I mean you might say eating terrible.
No I just mean Standard American Diet.
I mean I saw I call it they gave me this
these blanket statements are a real
issue.
And that's one of the reasons why your
diet is fascinating because like you
know I don't think you can make blanket
statements when it comes to people and
diet.
You know that I think there's some
people out there that are damn food
dumpsters.
You could throw anything in there and
they're fine.
They just don't care unseemly issues.
Then closer to that.
Yeah.
My brother is pretty well he's not so
good with it like lactose but he's
pretty stable compared to me anyway.
Well you know Michael Phelps the Olympic
swimmer.
Yeah.
It's like 10000 hours a day in several
pizzas.
Yeah I know.
I read about him fucking jacked has no
problems at all he's not fat.
It's sad because it but that's an issue
of enormous like expenditure of energy.
I mean he's yeah absolutely exercising
in his body as ridiculous cowardly
calorie requirements.
Yeah caloric.
So yeah I mean it's it's hard to say but
I think sedentary lifestyle is a giant
part of it.
But most of what people do is what we're
doing right now.
Most of what people do is sit down.
But is that because they don't feel like
running around because some people like
people who exercise.
Generally you have to put in a little
bit of effort to make yourself go
exercise but a lot of people who are
overweight and sick don't have enough
energy to do that.
I don't know about that.
Some of them maybe but I think some of
them just don't have discipline.
There's an issue with that as well.
There's also an issue of momentum.
You're not used to doing it.
It's not a part of your life.
It's not something that you're
accustomed to pushing yourself.
There's been many many many many many
many many days where I don't want to
work out.
I just didn't feel like I had the energy
and I just forced myself.
And I think there's very few people out
there that know how to force themselves.
That's a learn.
Yeah that's a learned skill.
Yeah.
That that kind of discipline and focus
you have to have like real rigid
requirements of yourself where you don't
allow yourself to back out of things and
you don't allow yourself to slack off.
And I don't think people put those kind
of requirements on themselves as if it's
it is a a daily principle of life like
what you must get done.
You know you must brush your teeth and
exercise for 45 minutes.
And if you did that I think you'd be
healthier and happier and your body
would perform more smoothly.
And if you require your body to do
things like that I think it rises to the
occasion.
There are very few people that have that
kind of discipline.
So because of that they come up with
excuses and excuses are a giant part of
the problem.
It's not simply a physical health issue.
There's also mental aspects of it.
And discipline is a big one.
I just know way too many people who are
weak mentally and I can't I can't just
chalk it off to only you know their
physical though the way they physically
feel because I felt like shit 100 times
and then I worked out and then I felt
way better.
Yeah it's just it's just a fact of life
that's real.
You know you just get the idea and
people don't know how to do that.
It's all.
And if you're used to doing this get in
your car sit down drive to the office
sit down go to the lunch sit down you
know go to the board meetings sit down
get in your car and on the way home sit
down get home in front of the TV sit
down then go to the gym fuck off do not
have any energy you know their bodies
not the debate is like oh don't have it
in me to do this and I don't believe
that I don't believe that I think it's
it's a lot of it is the mindset so I
partly agree with that but because I
know I'm like I was a very sick
individual a different case you have
real legitimate diagnosed physical
issues.
This is a very different thing.
You have a severe autoimmune disorder.
I mean listen you get your hip replaced
you're fucking 17 yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
You don't hear that this is different.
I'm talking about the average fat fuck
you just sit around being lazy.
That's really what it is.
It's like I'm sure a lot of it is diet
and a lot of that diet affects their
physical health but there's been many
many people that have just put their
foot down and said enough I'm gonna
change my life and they they don't take
an excuses and they feel way way better
diet is most certainly a part of that
but there's also a discipline aspect and
these things are not mutually exclusive.
They exist together they're all together
there's and they work symbolically the
way you.
Your mindset affects the choices you
make with your diet and the mindset also
affects the choices you make in terms of
like whether or not you require yourself
to exercise and I think these are these
are critical aspects that people like to
gloss over or they like to make excuses
about and they get very angry if you
don't accept those excuses.
And that's a sign that they're trying to
they're trying to enforce this standard
in this idea and push it on you and give
themselves an excuse.
It's one of the reasons why they get
angry.
It's one thing if someone has a legit
physical issue like you do but there's a
lot of people who do not.
They just have poor diet choices.
They have a sedentary lifestyle and they
have the momentum of this sedentary
lifestyle that's holding them back.
They're accustomed to being lazy OK I
kind of kind of agree.
I just from like my perspective I've
seen my dad and he was very like you can
see from the videos from 2014 before he
started going low carb and everything.
He was carrying about 50 extra pounds.
Right.
And he didn't exercise and he didn't
have enough energy to exercise doesn't.
But he didn't look at those lights
right.
That's not true.
He just didn't do it.
No I I don't believe that.
When you say didn't have enough energy
to exercise.
Did he walk around.
Well yeah.
You want to drag yourself through things
and you can drag yourself through an
exercise routine.
You can well you must.
You most certainly can.
He most certainly can.
You don't have to do a lot.
You have to do something.
You walk up hills.
You jump a little rope.
You take a little tiny kettlebell you do
a couple cleans impresses you do a few
pushups and do a few sit ups.
You get your blood pumping.
You're moving.
You're alive.
You're exercising to say you don't have
enough extra energy to exercise.
That's crazy.
Can you walk to the refrigerator then
you can exercise.
I'm not saying that you have to run
marathons.
You can exercise and everyone should
fucking exercise.
I agree.
Everyone should exercise.
Don't ever say.
People are so crazy.
They want you to believe I don't have
the energy to exercise.
God damn it everyone does if you're a
liar.
I cannot say I believe that I've been
there.
I know I'm a different case but I've
seen my dad there and then here's the
thing.
Once he fixed up his diet once he went
to this corner of her diet he's
exercising now Choi's got less weight on
his body.
He feels better and he has energy that's
wonderful.
He could have exercise then too.
He would've felt shittier for sure when
it felt as good as you feeling now.
But to give people as excuse I don't
have the energy to exercise that is
crazy to say Can you walk to the fucking
refrigerator.
Yes well you can exercise.
You don't have to do anything crazy just
walk around the block.
There's a there's 80 year old ladies who
take yoga with me they're fucking really
old and they're in there they're going
after it.
They could easily say I don't have the
energy to do that but they don't.
It's a mental attitude.
They make a decision.
Yeah I agree.
Like there's a lot of it's discipline
you're gonna get people who just don't
exercise to kill yourself you have to go
to a cross fit class and try to do the
work out of the day.
You'd have to go nuts and do clean
impresses with 150 pounds.
You'd have to do that but you to do
something just get your blood moving
your body has requirements it wants to
move.
It really does and when it does you feel
better.
But people like to give themselves this
excuse I do not have the energy to do
this.
Whatever you decide that that's true.
But if you watch a motivational video
this 100 of them on YouTube thousands
even go watch one you'll get fired up
like fuck it I'm going to jump some rope
you jumps from rope you do something
just do some pushups do something do
some bodyweight squats you'll feel
better but it's also like learning that
learning that and having that as a part
of your daily life it has to be you know
again I'm not talking about someone like
you who is in the throes of this
autoimmune disorder where you're getting
your hip replaced at 17 I'm not talking
about someone with like serious
degenerative illness I'm talking about
just a regular person who's overweight
you can do it.
There's a lady who's like 450 pounds it
takes yoga with me she's enormous she's
in there was probably really
embarrassing.
Very hard to do.
Yeah you know and she's in there did
you.
We could.
Anyone could do it.
We can do it.
And again I'm not saying do what Michael
Phelps does.
I'm just saying just do something.
Got to do something.
We have fucked up lifestyles.
Yeah.
The lifestyle.
We'll have are just the human body is
not designed to sit down all day and
it's certainly not designed to be stuck
in traffic and be in an office and just
be you know fluorescent lights sitting
there in front of a fucking computer
monitor watching your soul get sucked
through the the LCD screen.
It's crazy.
Yeah yeah I agree.
I think we've got to be really careful
with just the way we describe things.
It's like say I don't have the energy to
do something to fuck off.
Stop.
I don't know.
I believe it still.
That was good.
But I'm still not convinced.
You still know I think.
Well I think you change your diet and
then you can exercise.
You can exercise without changing your
diet.
There's a lot of people do.
They do yeah.
But I'm not as partly that's discipline.
Yes but partly that's being able to I'm
still I don't know you haven't.
So what do you think is holding them
back.
Well I think if you're carrying around
extra weight like a quite a bit of extra
weight and you say I don't have enough
energy there's something serious going
on that isn't just oh I have a few extra
pounds.
I don't think we know exactly what that
looks like but a lot of that has to do
with energy.
I mean dad was sleeping here sleeping
for two hours a day in the middle of the
day and he was impossible to wake up.
He couldn't wake up and like shake them
and couldn't wake him up.
Dad told me he was on a standard diet of
legs sandwiches and pasta things on
hands.
Yeah have that big insulin dump.
Yeah.
Yeah but I mean most people who don't
have enough energy are in a lot of those
people don't realize like we were eating
whole grains.
We didn't know that whole grains were
just grains.
We had the whole grains were healthy.
So I was having sandwiches for lunch
because I was having cheese and bread
and that was protein.
Right your dad has autoimmune disease
disorders as well.
Yeah.
A significant right.
Crucial to the depression was at 17 if
that was the main one that was very
significant.
Yeah I think you know it's hard to do.
It's hard to also figure out like what
is depression.
We say no sign of depression to the
person doesn't have depression like
myself.
I hear that and I go OK.
What does that mean.
Yeah it does it.
Mean you feel bad.
What does it mean does it mean there's
like a thick wet blanket over your life
that you can't get out.
Yeah it means like there's a couple of
things.
The closest it's it's impossible to
think of when you're not depressed but
the closest I've get to is if you're in
a really really stressful situation and
a whole bunch of things go wrong at the
same time that's stress you feel is kind
of like a really really mild version of
being depressed.
Being depressed is like if you look at
something the colors seem muted you
don't get joy out of anything.
This color the sky reds like just colors
everything's in gray scale kind of feels
like you're walking through molasses and
then you have a whole bunch of anxieties
pop up all the time that are like worst
case scenarios of everything in your
entire life that won't happen but that's
all you can think of all the time that
things partly anxiety but it's hell like
I having arthritis I would choose
arthritis a million times over then this
depression just wrecks you.
So what leads you to the carnivore died.
This lady has been living on it for 18
years.
You read about her and that she's still
alive without eating and her Lyme
disease gone and she looks great.
There's a before and after picture.
She loves taking vitamins as well.
Nothing nothing beef and salt.
Right.
So this is what you hear so this
anecdotal story is what leads you to
give that a try.
Well.
Yeah this is 2017 so December must.
Yeah.
So not quite a year.
So I switched over and then I had these
transient transition symptoms diarrhea.
Yeah.
That was basically it was craving.
It's bold to hang in there with six
weeks diarrhea.
Yeah but the alternative was like
anxiety and itching and arthritis.
Well you were also probably at the end
of your rope right where you're like Oh
yeah.
Like I said I can't even eat miso soup
right.
There's nothing else like I don't care
about salad.
I've already given up everything I love.
Take it away.
And then after six weeks it got better.
And then I reintroduced all of not went
badly and I thought OK I'm done with the
reintroduction.
I'm just sticking with meat.
Your dad said he's going to try to
reintroduce mushrooms Yeah.
We'll see how that goes.
He seems to be weirdly sensitive to like
in the same category as me.
But instead of getting arthritis and all
these other things as well he just gets
the depression which is the worst one.
Well
he said he he introduced something to
his diet and he didn't sleep for like 24
days.
Yeah.
So it's not even possible.
Wow.
Dead.
No.
That's what it felt like I had the same
weight I had the same thing.
We ate the same thing.
I think it was sulfates in apple cider
in a stew I made.
I don't know what it was.
I think that's what it was.
And yeah.
And then there was the edging came back
and the doom came in.
This depression came in and then.
That's that's weird and it hasn't
happened very many times.
But I got stuck with insomnia and it
felt like we weren't sleep.
So you slept like a little bit and you
wake up.
Probably yeah.
It does not what it felt like but I'm
sure you know it's not physically
possible to stay awake for that long but
I don't feel like sleeping.
What's the world record that someone's
ever stayed awake.
I think it's only like 10 days.
Yeah I think it's 11:00 10:00 or 11:00.
Yeah something along those lines.
God why would he do that.
Was it just a task version.
Eleven days and twenty five minutes.
Twenty five minutes.
That's what it takes with that dude with
Down a half deep.
Wow that's crazy.
So I must unless you dad stomp the shit
out of that world record.
No I'm sure he was sleeping but it was
like it was you know it didn't feel like
that and it wasn't very much.
It's just crazy that one thing.
What do you remember what it was that he
reintroduced to his dance that that was
might have been.
It wasn't a reintroduction it was.
We were just still eating apples at that
point and it was a cider and it had salt
fights at it and I looked at it and
thought whatever it's like parts per
million sulphide it'll be fine
and then that was the only thing that
was new.
So do you think that as you get onto
this elimination diet and you start
taking things out you get what you get.
Yeah.
You get more sensitive cards like one of
things that that I noticed in a big way
was when I cut sugar out of my diet.
If I have sugar now like if I go crazy
and have an ice cream sundae I hit a
fuckin wall so hard where I can't even
get up.
To sit down the cast my oh it takes like
an hour or two for it to get out of my
system.
So for like an hour.
And I'm like oh God I feel like shit.
And then two hours later I go OK it's
done.
That's it.
It's two hours.
Yeah about two hours.
It's like 24 days for me.
Yeah.
Oh I believe you.
I believe you.
But for me it's just for two hours.
I mean and again it's not I'm not
depressed for two hours.
I just feel like I have a brick in my
stomach.
Yeah.
And I feel like I'm on a tranquilizer.
Yeah yeah yeah.
So most of the that's how I lived all my
life.
No it's good tranquilizer like it's
idiopathic hyper Sonia was like I was
falling asleep during exams.
I drove home on the highway one time
when I was 22 and I was falling asleep
at the wheel and I was like Oh my God.
Like I can't stay awake passing out.
And I moved over into a lane and a truck
came by and honked at me and I was like
home my God I'm going to die.
And then I went on Adderall Whoa like I
need to stay awake or I'm going to die.
RFE RL Oh yeah yeah.
I'm off of everything and the Adderall
so I stopped taking the
immunosuppressants when I cut out gluten
just to see how my arthritic flare ups
would go if anything would happen then I
was then I got off the antidepressants
November 2015 and then my fatigue lifted
in January 2016.
So I got off the Adderall right away
then mm mm hmm.
I was taking a lot and it was great when
I was in that like feeling like I was on
tranquilizers It was great.
But once you don't need it it's kind of
awful being on that amount of
amphetamine all the time.
I know so many people are on that.
It's so disturbing to me how many people
are taking that and talk about their
productivity and they're always it makes
you feel like you're being productive.
I don't know if it actually makes you
more productive and it just destroys
your short term memory does it destroyed
mine.
I was taking a lot those on 40
milligrams a day on the morning long
release this one of those things I've
always thought about trying I'm like
maybe one day if you have energy if you
have energy I don't think he gives you a
kick.
Like if you're exhausted all the time
it's just kind of unpleasant and it
makes you like weirdly anti-social.
Mm hmm.
OK so you haven't been on this died for
a year now.
What has changed once you got over the
diarrhea.
What has the change been like.
So the arthritis and like the auto
immune stuff went away fairly quickly
when I was still having diarrhea and I
went away.
The mood started to pick up six weeks
into the diet and then in May so I'd
been December driver.
March April May.
So five months into it I had a huge
improvement.
So things just got better and better
everyday and I finally got to the point
where I was pre pregnancy.
So since May
as I would say it's still getting
better.
So it's only been three months.
So you've been OK.
No I've been OK since January but my
mood went from like eight to like a nine
and a half.
Like great.
In May.
So it's feeling good after I started
after this first six weeks.
But then things got a lot better and may
seem to be just improving now.
What kind of bloodwork are you getting
while you're doing all this.
Are you going and getting tested for
nutritional deficiencies.
Because one of the issues that many
people who are nutritionists or who are
studying biology have with this
carnivore diet is that meat just meat is
very deficient in many many nutrients.
It's just it's very deficient in vitamin
C is deficient in several things that we
think that you need in order to to live.
Yeah well I did get bloodwork done
because people were asking and not
because I particularly trust bloodwork
because my bloodwork was always pretty
normal.
I was always low in zinc and vitamin D
since I was a kid.
Even when you had severe arthritis.
Yeah.
Everything was normal.
I had no blood markers and I was like
dying but Jesus.
What about for inflammation my white
blood cell count was high.
Give me a sign of infection.
Right.
So that was high my vitamin D and my
zinc were low.
Right.
But that's not what showed up.
But that wouldn't be normal right.
If you went and you got your blood
tested and they showed you you have a
high white blood cell count that would
go there's an issue here.
Yes.
It wasn't abnormal enough to have caused
the problems I was experiencing.
But how about how how different was it
from the normal white blood cell count.
Well I had white bloods raised white
blood cell count and I had white blood
cells in my urine.
And that's that's a little weird because
that is generally like while some sort
of bacterial infection which I didn't
have symptoms of.
Mm hmm.
So that was a little weird but that was
never focused on from the doctors.
Why not.
Well that seems like that's that's an
issue.
If normal people don't have that and you
have problems that normal people don't
have.
I would say my blood work is not.
I mean your blood work is not normal.
That's not normal.
No but I mean I was on all the
medications they could put me on.
So there wasn't and they never looked at
diet so I was kind of at a standstill.
Well but you when you said that you
don't trust blood work and then.
Well I did get it done right.
Mostly for the blog so that everybody
could see I wasn't dying.
I can pull it up.
OK.
That was one of the issues with Shaun
Baker.
Shawn got his blood work done and one of
the things that people noticed is that
there's quite a few issues there.
And one of them was very very low
testosterone which is crazy because he's
a gorilla.
Yeah he's a big huge 6 foot 5 250 pound
dude.
So it's like well he didn't look
deficient in testosterone like what the
hell is going on here.
Yeah I don't have testosterone readings.
He also said that part of that might you
know he I have gone back and forth about
this.
He said part of that might have been
that had to do with taking the test when
he had done a very heavy weight lifting
workout the day before.
If he'd done squats and deadlifts and
all kinds of stuff and so maybe broke
his body down a bit.
Yeah.
Kind of makes sense.
I'll be nice first.
Like a medical professional to take some
of these groups of people doing this
diet and just do a study.
Mm hmm.
So we could actually get some
information.
Yeah.
Instead of like everything's anecdotal
and I put my stuff up but just because
so I can show it to you but everything
is normal.
Everything is normal.
My Farrington is slightly slightly
elevated but like fair it's an iron.
OK.
So that's slightly elevated because
you're eating a little lightly red meat
but that's not bad.
Not necessarily.
And it was still like my doctor said he
didn't care it wasn't elevated enough
but like what about vitamins.
So for vitamins
vitamins my zinc is still low.
My Vitamin D still low that hasn't
recovered.
It's been like that and it's been like
out forever.
Well it's hard in Canada like I have
some pictures on Instagram and I'm Green
because there's no light for like six
months
and then I'm outside all summer so I'm
probably deficient.
I think that has something to do with
the auto immune disorder.
I tried supplementing with really high
dose vitamin D and didn't see any
benefits.
So I hope I don't take supplements
anymore.
The high dose vitamin D.
Yeah.
I tried once when I was 21 for about a
year and then again when I was doing on
the low carb diet.
Well what about now when you're issues
with vitamin D or in your blood.
Just got my bloodwork back.
Okay so I was doing no no supplements so
that I could see what happened.
Also I wouldn't recommend high dose of
vitamin D.
Oh just recommend supplementing with a
normal dose of vitamin D.
I think I'm just going to wait and see
and get tested in a year.
I'm not too concerned and see what
happens because here's here's what's
interesting.
When I went to the low carb diet my B
vitamins were low.
So this was during the pregnancy I got
this first test and it was my b twelve
was fine but everything else was low
folate was low B one B three B six and
Biogen were all low on the low carb
diet.
Right on my natural path said maybe you
have a microbiome problem whatever that
means whenever someone says my natural
process they just go Oh yeah.
What else.
I was like need a costume like that.
Yeah.
Crystal with you at all times.
You know what they were they're telling
me to cut out gluten for years and I was
like What do you know.
Right crazy person.
Yeah I could have probably stopped you
need to stop some pressure on your wall
put a Jewish culture above your bed.
That'll help.
Mm hmm.
Anyway this new micro nutrients test the
vitamin D and count not calcium vitamin
D and zinc are still low but all my bees
have gone up so none of my bees folate
is still borderline but it was deficient
before and all my other bees are have
gone up to normal.
What about Vitamin C O vitamin C was
always normal Vitamin C hasn't changed
at all.
That's fascinating because that's one of
the ones I think people are deficient if
you are on this diet.
Well I did some background reading
because I've been I thought people died
of scurvy if they didn't eat vegetables
just like everybody thinks that well.
But it turns out vitamin C and glucose
compete.
So if you don't eat glucose you just
don't use as much vitamin C..
Mm hmm.
Yeah and I haven't been supplementing my
vitamin C is totally fine.
Yeah.
Sean Baker said something about
something along those lines.
That was some of the vitamin C that
you're taking in is competing with
glucose and that you need far less of it
and it's far more effective.
So there is some vitamin C in beef.
Yeah.
Are you telling the grass fed beef or
you do care.
So initially I tried to get rid of all
the variables because I didn't know what
I was reacting to.
So I was eating grass fed antibiotic
free.
All that stuff and now I'm eating mostly
I try to stay away from the antibiotic
and hormone meat but I'm eating grain
finished because it's just so much
cheaper than grass fed and it doesn't.
I have no problems with it.
How would you know whether or not beef
has antibiotics or hormones in it you
just trust the labeling right.
That's it but I.
But I've gone out to eat in restaurants
where I'm sure the meats lower quality
and I haven't had an autoimmune flare up
with that.
Mm.
Hmm.
So when you go out to eat you know one
of things you posted the other day was
that you had steak that had pepper on
it.
Yeah I had pepper on Monday pepper like
ground pepper and you're freaking out.
I was freaking out on Monday.
Yeah that was like I don't know what
happens.
It's OK.
I'm fine.
But yeah I was freaking out I was
stressed out for the whole day.
But it's like if it flared first of all
these flare ups don't happen instantly.
So it gives you enough time to freak out
about if they're going to happen for a
couple of days.
Right.
And then it's like a month of an
autoimmune disorder and depression and
brain fog and not being able to think is
horrible.
So yeah I am freaked out but I'm OK.
The one thing I found really helps.
The only thing I found that helps these
reactions is an infrared sauna.
If I get in there like once a day and
sweat only an infrared one what about a
regular one.
Do you know.
Honestly no I don't know.
You don't know.
So the idea just elevated heat
temperature whether it's infrared or
not.
Yeah I don't know if it's.
I've just read all the benefits of
infrared but I haven't any fits over a
regular sauna.
Wow.
There's like longevity studies from
Finland.
Those are done in the regular sauna.
That's a regular sauna.
Yeah.
The ones that are done that show the
decrease of mortality of 40 percent.
It's a regular sauna regular sauna.
Yeah.
But mitochondrial helps you go that.
Please there's a study maybe Rhonda
Patrick has it up on our Web site but
because I asked her whether I should get
a regular sauna or a infrared and she
said the studies that were done were
done with a regular sauna.
And she said the real issue is that your
body is producing heat shock proteins.
So whether it's infrared or regular the
whole.
The real issue is your body's in this
extreme 170 degree temperature produces
these cytokines and these cytokines
cytokines taglines and your body is
reacting to this incredible temperature
and this is what produces anti
inflammation effect.
I would think for someone like you with
arthritis in particular anything that
reduces inflammation would be a great
benefit.
So yeah.
No it's sorry.
Awesome.
I just if I'm reacting like Sonia makes
me feel like 20 percent better.
Like a lot better.
Laughter I get out.
Yeah.
If I'm not reacting I don't sweat as
much when I get in and it's nice but
it's not like a huge relief like it is
when I'm reacting.
It's giant for me.
I mean I don't have the autoimmune
issues that you have but boy for me it's
just it's a game changer.
Yeah.
Get in there for 20 minutes half hour
and I get out there it's just like
everything just feels better.
Yeah yeah.
And it hits me like about 20 minutes
after I get out and I get this mood up
and it's just like once your body I
think that what that is is your
temperature normalizes your body
temperature normalizes after you're out
of that heat and then everything's just
like Oh yeah.
No it's great.
It's great.
Have you done the crime therapy.
Yeah.
Similar feeling right.
Not as good I don't think.
No but similar feeling it's better
actually for pain so I have my ankle
replacement still gives me problems
because it's an ankle replacement so
I've done trial therapy for that and
that's works better for pain I think
than the sauna does.
Now what do they do when they replace
your ankle.
Do they cut off the bottom of the joint
and recap it and put something else
there.
So they cut off yeah.
They cut off the bottom of the tibia
it's a big bone tibia and then they
replace the top of the Tallis.
It sucks and I got it done in 2009 when
the ankle joints weren't as good as they
are now.
So now I'm left with this like old ankle
joint and I'm 26 so I have to get it
looked at because it's giving me
problems.
You going to get another one.
Oh God no I hope not.
I think they're just gonna try and fix I
had it some super dope carbon fiber a
new model.
I know they don't have that.
Nobody's like making anything cool.
No no.
It seems like they're constantly
improving that I mean it looks like on
YouTube but that's not really what it
looks like in real life.
No.
Now it's like maybe I could just get a
new foot I could get a better foot right
on a new foot to a new foot.
Well some robot foot maybe salon.
Like what the fuck is this.
Depends on the robot foot.
You'd be down for a robot foot if it
like took away all your pain.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
If I could run again I can't run with an
ankle replacement.
What about you.
Hip replacement can I have replacements
resign.
Yeah but they I have friends that got a
hip replacement they said of running out
of the question.
So I love the idea.
Like you said no way.
You can't run.
I could run on the hip replacement
really and I can limp along with my
ankle but the hip replacement gives me
no problems.
It's great but I thought that the load
that is placed on the hip is not.
I don't think they recommend activities
like that all the time all the time.
But even like a watch an elliptical
that's pretty low impact.
And I can't do that because of my ankle
but my hip is fine.
Have you ever tried to verse a climber.
No.
We have to know that.
So when angled like a beam like with
handles on it and you do this
phenomenal cardio it's amazing.
Works your core because you're at an
angle so you got you're kind of planking
almost a little bit while you're doing
it.
Oh wow.
Yeah.
My or sadder.
Do you do sprints with it and then do
two bodies like 2010s.
Wow 20 seconds on 10 second break 20
seconds on ten second break.
Phenomenal huh.
Yeah.
One of the best exercises in terms of
cardio huh.
I stopped.
So did you do a bike.
No I can't really do anything with his
ankle but I did start it.
Yeah it's a huge pain.
I'm gonna need to get surgery I think
I'm getting something done in January.
And what are they gonna do.
So basically bone has grown into the
joint so it's basically fused.
So I just don't have any movement and it
kind of hurts and it doesn't hurt like
it hurt when I needed it replaced but it
hurts so they're going to go in and
clean out all the bone and pray that
that works.
Jesus.
So that's that's what my January is
gonna be.
Does this make you think that like if
you got on this die.
Yeah.
When you were younger you could have
ordered all the shots is why I'm not
very pleased with the medical community.
What the hell do they know me.
They didn't know back but they could
have said I don't know.
They could've look to the celiac thing
and I would have at least been clued in
that gluten was a problem and maybe just
removing that would've been good enough.
Well it seems that the amount of
research that they would have to do.
I mean think about how many different
things you have to look out to come to
that illusion the time you had to spend
like three years.
Yeah.
And Canada has public.
I mean you have public health care
right.
So it's it's it's weird right.
Not as motivated.
They're not it's not ideal for people
with very special problems.
Right.
Good for general public and it's great
if you don't have money and you need to
get taken care of but they have a lot of
people coming in and out.
Right.
It's constant.
I'm getting this surgery done in North
Carolina.
Wow.
Just fuckin turn your back on Canada
huh.
I could wait around for like three and a
half years for a surgeon that's not as
good.
Yeah yeah.
That this infrared thing I'm finding
very interesting stuff.
I remember reading what you said but I'm
not finding that and I've only found
stuff that I can't find.
Ben Greenfield I think it was a
transcription of a podcast today with
Rhonda.
Mm hmm.
And something else very similar which is
information from Dr. Jill Kahn.
Mm hmm.
That says only sunlight sunlight and far
infrared sonnets have been shown to
increase core temperature for effective
detoxification because they get you can
stay longer in the threshold area they
want to around one hundred and thirty
degrees you can be there up to forty
five minutes or so.
Mm hmm.
And you I guess you can't unless you can
withstand it in a trailer heat one
because it's heating the air around you
not light heating your body.
Oh interesting.
Yeah.
So the infrared one is heating your body
in specific rather than you being in the
heat.
Correct.
Interesting.
So you can do it longer and that's where
the benefits.
What how much longer.
How long you supposed to it said at
least 30 minutes.
But that's what I do anyway.
I don't know the difference.
So infrared song is good if you're a
pussy.
So that's why I didn't want to say that.
But hey maybe that's what they're saying
I don't know.
Well it seems like you get more benefit
with less suffering that's what it would
seem like because you could do it
longer.
I think that's what they're getting at
but I don't know if that's the reason
why I got enough people off to just quit
after 20 minutes and I can't get to the
30.
Well people do man they get does get
uncomfortable with it but if you could
have if you get the same benefits you
could avoid the discomfort why wouldn't
you do that right.
Mm hmm.
It also just it's just uncomfortable
right before you start sweating when
you're like oh I'm really hot and then
you start sweating and you're it's not
as bad.
There's a new company that's making an
infrared sauna that you work out in.
It's got a chin up bar in and it's got
all these like like resistance cables.
The other part of this too which is I'd
have to go more into science is that I
don't know is that the LCD is like the
infrared light can penetrate your skin
whereas the heat maybe can't because
it's just heat.
It's heating up your skin.
It's not like infrared is literally a
wave.
It's a lightweight.
It's a different kind of it invigorates
your mitochondria so many works and that
love.
The studies that they did in was in
Norway Finland Finland.
Maybe they just didn't have infrared
there.
Maybe I maybe I don't know because like
those Russian Banias they do the regular
saw on us these regular saw on us and
they go hot cold hot cold and they've
had some pretty awesome benefits of
that.
And so there might be something to that
because they're using light like
dentists using light now to harden
fillings.
So that's pretty new.
Yeah science.
She Blinded Me With Science.
Fascinating stuff.
It is all very fascinating stuff.
But so sauna definitely helps you either
way.
Yeah yeah.
And I think like I've read some studies
on it working out a mitochondrial level.
I don't know anything about it.
I'm just there's something to it and it
after about half an hour is the only
thing that's helped.
I've tried like I tried everything to
get rid of these reactions faster like
detoxification things or mostly just
different weird different sort of
detoxification things and nothing's
helped except the sauna they still last
for as long with they're not as awful.
So I was telling you that this guy Kevin
Bass who's P.H.
Dean a scientist and he contacted me and
I contacted him put on my glasses I can
see you better.
And he we went back and forth about this
online and so he sent me a bunch of
stuff what he thinks.
And one of them is nutrient deficiency
and that
immuno suppression from a nutrient
deficiency and that in the ideas that
maybe in having less nutrients and
having less that you're a dietary immuno
suppression V A deficiency might be
helping you.
Oh and he said basically crazier things
have happened and that you reported
still having symptoms when you get sick
even on a carnivore diet.
And he said this shows that the
carnivore diet is a symptomatic
treatment.
It's not because she's removed the
offending antigen but yeah so I don't
even know if I understood all that
properly.
Well this is a very long.
He wrote a very very long piece on this
and I appreciate that he took the time
to do this.
One of the things that is saying is like
Vitamin A and that this this that this
diet could be vitamin A deficient
Vitamin C deficient we went over the
thing is I have an E deficient vitamin K
deficient.
So you got your results back so you got
tested in my vitamin K.
Everything's good is normal vitamin A's
normal normal like above it says
anything above 30 is okay for vitamin K
to minus 40 everything about 70 is okay
for vitamin A mind seventy nine mm hmm.
He said also that a lot of your symptoms
including joint destruction fatigue
depression etc. can be caused by the
drugs that are used to treat rheumatoid
arthritis although our rheumatoid
arthritis came first though.
Mm hmm.
Right.
But then the joint destruction was that.
How do you test was that post that you
being on those medications were those
studies even done.
How do you test that.
I mean it's the drugs or the arthritis
causing it.
I don't know.
I mean this is his take on this is the
potential scenarios.
I mean without rejecting it totally.
You were on those drugs far far earlier
than your joints destroyed right.
Yeah I started the drugs.
Grade 4 and then grade eleven.
Mm hmm.
Were the replacements.
Yeah.
Look this is this whole thing is a very
fascinating subject because people are
not having the response that
nutritionists would like them to have no
right nutritionist would like you guys
to be freaking out falling apart.
And it seems to be doing well.
I have a friend of mine lives in San
Diego who's been on the carnivore diet
for a while and you know he's a Navy
SEAL.
He said he feels fucking fantastic.
You said you know he said You just tried
it out see what it was like.
He's never felt better in his whole
life.
Yeah elimination diets.
This is this is a big thing like getting
getting yourself down to a very small
number of foods
you know and that this seems to have
some sort of a a large benefit for
people as well.
Yeah I mean I think it would depend on
the foods you know it's like your body
not having too much to manage.
And people with
autoimmune disorders and diseases.
Having less to manage could potentially
be what.
What is benefiting you as well.
I don't play as last though because if
you survived only off of soy you're not
going to do well.
I think it depends what you're eating.
One of the things that he's saying too
is that when you get sick the systemic
inflammation probably opens up your
intestinal barrier which causes auto
immune systems to kick in again and said
the same thing happens with any food
that causes your intestinal barrier to
open up.
He said Why is this happening I don't
understand and that you and your father
both think this could be some sort of
hereditary thing.
Have you guys done any twenty three and
me test.
Yeah.
And what is that.
I have an genotype for a different gene
disorders perhaps.
Yeah.
Nothing showed up.
I ran it I ran it through Rhonda Patrick
has something on her Web site right.
I ran it through that I ran it through
Prometheus.
Nothing shocking shows up.
I have a celiac Gene.
Dad doesn't.
So that's not exactly the issue.
That was it.
Wow.
The whole thing is just it's one of the
more interesting things is how people
they always want to attach all these
other things to it that environmental
concerns and the concern for you know
the the health and welfare of these
animals and that you're supporting
factory farming and always that it gets
very it gets very ideological.
Oh yes super fast real quick.
Right.
But does not we're talking about.
No I also I don't like I'm concerned
about other people who are suffering as
much as I was suffering.
Yeah that's it.
Right before you're concerned with
animals like everything a way before
like try living.
If your choice is to live with an
autoimmune disorder and like die slowly
that way you can do that and not eat
meat if you want to.
Well this.
It's also I think a disingenuous
argument because 97 percent of the
people in the world eat meat or
something.
So it's easy to tell other people that
when you're not experiencing those
symptoms it's also.
Yeah.
I mean
definitely it's definitely easier if
you're not experiencing those symptoms
but there's so much meat eating going on
already.
And if you if if people really can
benefit greatly from just an all meat
diet
we're going to tell them Don't do that.
Go vegan and keep us pagan and be
covered in hives and itching and and
being depressed states the rest of your
life.
Yeah.
It's just it's such a hot subject and I
feel like this is something that we're
gonna have more insight on over the next
few years.
Oh yeah.
We're starting to study it now and it's
starting to be mean.
You know Shawn Baker who's you know he's
a physician and then you've got some
really dedicated athletes that are
trying it now.
You know Zach bitter.
Mm hmm.
Who heal what does he owe on the North
American record for 24 hour race.
Wow.
Or if not for 24 hours for 100 miles he
ran 100 miles in 11 hours and 40 minutes
which is how fucking insane.
And he eats almost nothing but meat.
Yes.
Almost his entire died.
He supplements with high levels of
glucose like those gels and shit like
that.
And Ramsey's carbs way up when he's
going to do 100 mile races and things
like that.
But that's that's honestly a ridiculous
requirement on his body.
He's Yeah.
He's asking his body to run 100 fucking
miles and 11 hours and 40 minutes.
Wow.
Yeah that's crazy.
He also weighs five pounds.
Yeah.
It's just.
He weighs like a hundred forty but it's
just you know his his his diet shows
that it is possible to do extreme
physical feats while while you're on
this.
Yeah he does a podcasts also with Shawn
Baker.
So this is something that people are
really starting to study now and there's
a lot of argument there's a lot of
hesitancy not anger.
Oh I've read some article today
criticizing you and your dad and now.
Yeah.
That's okay.
I find it kind of like I can understand
a lot of people who go on that kind of
raw diet get really like vegan Haiti.
Well that's what I was doing.
They were.
Well that's true.
But what they were doing is they're
going off about the environment.
This was like like methane gas produced
by cows.
I don't think I saw this article.
It's just it's not it's not a good
argument because this is this is
happening like if you're a person.
OK I'm not saying that you we don't all
have a responsibility to do our part to
try to save the environment.
But if you're a person who is deathly
ill you go to the supermarket there's a
lot of fucking beef you can go buy beef.
It's right there.
Yeah.
If you could buy that beef and it fixes
you what.
Why don't you stop and think about the
ecological concerns the environmental
concerns and then the physical concerns
of people that are forced to take on
these fucking ridiculous pharmaceutical
medications.
Oh my God times years into their lives
and think about you're also empowering
these pharmaceutical companies and
they're lobbying to stop natural natural
cures.
They're they're trying to make kratom
illegal.
There's there's a lot of thuggery that's
involved in pharmaceutical companies
that we're well aware of.
A lot of cherry picking studies.
Yeah they'll do 100 hundred studies one
of them shows that there might be some
benefit to this.
Ninety nine shows it fucks you up and
they ignore those and they're allowed to
do this.
There's a lot of weird shit that we
really should take into consideration
before we support any sort of
pharmaceutical alternative and
pharmaceutical drugs aren't demons.
There's a lot of people that benefit
greatly from pharmaceutical drugs.
I did.
I don't think I would have been able to
figure this out unless I'd been on
Adderall and had the energy to Google
I'm sure.
I mean look there's these benefits it's
not they're not all bad.
They're not all good.
But I don't like that argument like hey
you know if you go on the carnivore diet
you're you're contributing to methane
that's fucking up the world.
OK.
Is it better or worse than
pharmaceutical drugs.
Is it better or worse than what they're
doing.
Is it better or worse the fact that foot
pharmaceutical drugs are in the water
supply.
You know they've they've done tests on
reservoirs and found pharmaceutical
drugs in them.
They've found pharmaceutical drugs in
rivers.
Fish.
Yeah.
Lakes.
Shut the fuck up.
There's a lot going on here.
Don't don't.
If you're going to look at this you
better look at it in a if you want to
make an argument against it you better
be balanced about this because otherwise
you're showing your ideological bend
like to say that it's about methane and
about cows and factory farming.
Not really no.
There's a lot going on.
There's a lot going on yeah.
It's this is a there's a long and
nuanced discussion and if you're you're
painting this this article in one way
and talking only about the negative
health and negative environmental
concerns that are associated with beef
production like look that beef
production is going on a matter with you
like it or not.
Yeah.
If you think we can curb it back and
slow it down a little bit that would be
wonderful.
But we have to look at it accurately you
know and also I believe they've proven
that methane see.
Google if this is true that Methane
production from cows and Sony makes
sense is far less when they're on a
natural diet when their pasture raised
than it is if they're corn fed.
But it makes sense because they have all
sorts of corn.
Yeah.
And also it's Ishan idea when they're
eating grain.
You know that that could easily be a
part of the problem is they're trying to
fatten these cows up quicker and they're
forced them to eat something that's not
natural for their body.
Have you ever seen that King Corn
documentary.
No great documentary but it's a real
corn.
Yeah it's a mindfuck corns and
everything.
Everything in your DNA like your whole
body's like filled with corn.
That's crazy because there's so much I
want to hear that it's crazy.
They've done.
They did.
These guys did tests on the carbon in
their body and they found corn is in
their body.
Yeah things the carbon in their body
whatever it was they just eat they go
through the supermarket aisle and they
find how many things have corn in them.
Yeah.
And that corn is subsidized by the
government.
So I grant soy and everything.
Yeah.
I did the articles but again this is
this is also part of the problem.
These people who are writing these
articles about your diet and about your
dad and in his heart.
This is just taking a shot at dad.
So yeah that's the other problem.
Yeah.
Certainly a lot of that.
But no the articles aren't great.
I mean it would be nice if someone
instead of saying maybe she didn't have
arthritis or maybe she's just placebo
balling herself into this.
Or maybe it's deprivation that's making
her feel better.
It could be nice if someone actually did
a study.
What does it say Jamie.
It says cows are being fed a new dye
they reduce the amount of burping and
cut emission methane by 20 percent.
From 2008 article.
What are they being fed.
What's this new diet didn't specifically
say I don't think they're being fed
other cows.
Cow what does it say.
Okay.
Special machines used to cut the straw.
But still huh.
Yeah.
Mixed with Slash edge silage wheat maize
soya or sugar beet which can be mixed
with.
Yeah.
See if you google
methane by cows who are pasture raised
methane by cows methane produced by cows
were grass fed.
See if there's land weirdly enough I
thought I read that it was grain fed
cows that produce less nothing really.
Which isn't what I would have guessed.
That's interesting grass fed cattle do
more methane what does produce produce
do more methane on the foot.
I'm not reading that grass cattle dupe.
Produce do more methane because it's
harder to digest OK obviously to produce
more methane because it's harder to
digest grass than grain.
However some argue grass that is
continually grazed by grass fed cattle
sequesters enough carbon to make up the
difference in methane.
OK.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
And healthy soil keeps carbon dioxide
underground in the atmosphere.
OK.
Yeah there's a big story behind there.
Right.
So that's why it's it's better for the
environment if they eat grass which
totally makes sense because they've been
eating grass for a million years.
Yeah yeah.
So so here you are here you are on this
diet now and you've started to what are
you doing consulting people online.
So I am now yeah I started about a month
ago and how what does that involve
people Skype me and basically.
Want to see me and how I'm still alive
only eating beef and then they ask me
how to cook and things because nobody
knows how to cook meat without anything
on it.
Well how do you cook like how do you
cook with just beef.
They don't know what to do.
They're like what oil do you use.
I don't use oil
I think most of these people I've been
talking to a lot of low I used tallow.
Used a lot but most of these people are
really sick and really desperate.
And they haven't had any help from the
medical system and so far and this is
completely true.
Anybody who's gone on to this like beef
and salt and water diet anybody I've
seen who's been able to stick through
that transition period where you get off
of carbs and explosive diarrhea not
everyone gets that Dad didn't get what
you want.
Like it seems to be 50/50.
It looks like the sicker you are seven.
Yeah.
No it seems to be but like seriously 50
percent of people and it seems like the
sicker you are the more likely you are
to get that and I don't all of its
inability to digest that amount of fat
right away or if it's a microbiome
switch or something but it seems to hit
50 percent of people the other 50
percent just switch over.
But everybody gets some sort of carb
withdrawal especially if you go from
like a standard American diet over then
it's insane cravings.
Oh do you get your ketones checked if
you don't like data.
I went to paleo effects this year.
And I got my ketones checked and they
were ridiculously high.
That was with a breath test.
Mm hmm.
And then I have like urine strep tests
which I know aren't as accurate but I
haven't gone out of ketosis my diets
about 80 percent calories from fat.
So it's them.
I eat ribs which are really fatty.
I eat ribeye sometimes but I find eating
more and more fat.
So just caloric Lee I'm getting about 80
percent from the fat.
Mm hmm.
See I eat a lot of meat but eating
really lean meat because I'm eating a
lot of wild game.
Mm hmm.
I'm not getting as much fat thank the
fats the good stuff.
But definitely it has a factor.
Mm hmm.
I just finished I didn't finish.
I'm halfway through a book called Fat of
the land by I'm going to butcher this
but like ville how your Steffensen and
it was this dude who went to live with
you at people in Canada for five years
and eight eight like they eight.
And it's amazing like historically it
shows how they dressed and how they
lived and what parts of the animal they
ate.
And so he lived off of what they eat
which was basically just meat and
sometimes eggs for five years and then
he came back.
I don't know if he was in England or in
the States but he came back and said hey
look how healthy I am.
All I eat is meat.
This isn't like the 30s.
And they said no way you're supposed to
have scurvy.
So him and his partner who is his last
names Anderson went to Bellevue horse
hospital and they stayed under monitor
just eating meat for a year.
And there are six studies done on them
and you can find them online.
And they monitored like vitamin levels.
They monitor over everything because
kidney function because back then like
nothing's changed in the last hundred
years they said you're supposed to be
dead of scurvy.
So I'm reading that book and he says.
That was one of the main things they
ate.
They also didn't eat any salt.
No they were eating like whale blubber
and seal fat.
So those lines mostly karibu karibu they
also has a brain though.
Yeah.
But they I ate he said they gave a lot
of the really lean cuts to the dogs so
they ate a lot of the fatty or cuts they
ate the brain.
They eat fat behind.
He goes into some serious detail a fat
behind the eyes.
Yeah.
They boiled a lot.
They boiled bones for the marrow so they
got fat out of that.
And then for part of the year they'd
also eat seal the fat behind the eyes.
Tastes like it's like bread like dough
you know that.
Yeah.
I haven't had that.
How did the first deer I shot.
We eat the fat behind eyes tastes.
It's like good.
No
no
it's it's not the best guy.
But it's it's definitely.
It's just weird like like doe.
That's weird huh.
Yeah it's a good book though and it
there is another person who was just
eating meat and for some reason people
have forgotten about him.
So like maybe the best deal would be
those really fat Japanese cows was Kobe
beef cows or why.
Yeah because those are fat as fuck.
Yes.
Those things you you look at those
marble cuts and you like when they're
doing a cow.
I don't know.
It's terrible.
Probably nothing good.
Yeah I think good.
Now those poor cows.
Yeah.
What I've been doing recently which is a
lot cheaper is getting ground beef which
is lean and adding tallow and just
frying it.
That makes sense and it's way cheaper
than steak but it's super fatty just
spoonfuls of tallow in there and you
just eat it is put in a bowl and eat it.
Are you getting bored with this.
No no not at all.
So after the first week sucked because
first line kind of sucks I was one of
the reason it sucked but I was also like
a missing salad.
I was having and I only went from Greens
down so it's a pretty easy transition
kinda by the rest your family almost
died as well as your whole mass.
Yeah he's on it as well.
Yeah really.
And how does he have any issues health
issues.
He was depressed and pretty severe
depression really.
Know what was causing his depression
like foods.
He had the same issues as me and I know
how that sounds but my dad was like this
seems to be genetic.
How can you have it too.
Well but so it's not genetic.
Hmm that's interesting.
Yeah.
Action.
Well he was like this is a little
incredulous.
Well I mean those food reactions were
kind of strange.
You know people have like weird
sympathetic disorders you know like
someone around them has something they
start to develop the same sense.
So that's what dad was thinking.
It wasn't like this though he'll turn
green his skin turns a different color
when he was the wrong thing.
Yeah I mean not like green but he gets
pale you can see it.
Huh.
Oh one thing I wanted to address when I
was on here in Sean Baker's episode he
said something about eating apples that
gave him low back pain and you were like
apples give you low back pain and people
in the comments were freaking out.
Well that's a symptom that happens to me
too.
And it's not over yet when my mood drops
I get lower back pain and so does dad.
And it's funny to freak out about to get
it but that's very commonly associated
with depression and it is triggered by
food with me too.
Well I know that that's triggered by
some people that have lower back issues
when they eat and flip inflammation
causing foods like pasta and sugar.
Yeah.
Mm hmm.
So I went to a physical therapist once
when I was having had a bulging disc in
my neck and she suggested that I cut out
gluten.
I thought she's a crazy person now what
are you talking about cut out gluten.
My cousin she was I know it sounds crazy
but a lot of these things cause issues
and they causes inflammation.
That was like the first steps that I
thought was the first idea.
Gluten.
Yeah.
Well also the first steps that I took to
understand that foods cause
inflammation.
I had never thought of that at all.
I thought oh no someone yanked on my
neck and then my next her and tried to
fix it.
How do you fix my neck.
And but when she was saying this that
the reduction of inflammation causing
foods would lead to healing in certain
issues.
I was very incredulous.
Sounds like some fucking wacky car Yeah.
Bullshit.
Yeah but there's something to it.
And you know there's there's something
too.
First of all the weight reduction soon
as you cut out all these sugary foods
and your body's just carrying less stuff
around you carrying less meat.
I mean and people don't realize how much
it has to do a workout do like a body
weight workout.
Now do that same body weight workout
with a 40 pound vest on it's way harder
fucking way harder.
Yeah.
And most people out there wandering
around Italy's 40 pounds overweight at
least 40 pounds.
Yeah it's a lot of weight.
A lot of weight.
You know I do this I have this this
backpack that I put metal plates on.
It's it's by this company called
outdoorsman.
And it's like a basically leg of the
frame of a hiking backpack.
He snap it in and it puts an Olympic
plate on the back and locks it in place
allow.
So that it really centers in your back
as opposed to like a lot of people do
weighted hikes but they put sandbags in
there and it kind of shifts and moves
around.
But this was like really centers in and
locks it in place.
But if I do 45 pounds and I go hiking
around like it kind of kicks my ass it's
hard going up and also 45 pounds.
Think about what most people just go
through life with a lot of people go.
Your dad was 50 50 pounds overweight.
Yeah.
Think of that.
It's a lot of weight on that whereas
your ass out that.
And then that's one of the reasons why
people say they don't have the energy to
exercise so carrying around all this way
their ass I was like it like really
heavy overweight persons people and I
look at their legs and like that dude
probably can kick through a wall.
Someone could teach him how to kick like
think about how much weight you're
carrying around the time their knees are
probably super strong like all the
tissue around their legs just constantly
carrying this heavy load upstairs.
Yeah.
If you could lose weight you'd probably
have amazing legs.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Now look at diet.
So how do you go though from this to
doing consulting and is it.
Is it a big leap to like.
I mean you're just trying to figure your
own life out to try to help other people
online.
You don't have a degree in nutrition or
anything.
Right.
God no.
Well but what am I going to get a degree
in nutrition for.
They still teach people eat grain so
that was never in the books.
Do you think that today like if you went
to a university today like a really good
school do you think there would still be
saying that grains are good.
Good idea to eat.
I do.
I don't know that so I could be wrong
but yeah I would say it's still pretty
food pyramid de
Well I don't know if they go the old way
with the like when you read and I don't
change them as all rice and wheat.
I don't think it's really changed.
I think it's like eat a good mix of Make
sure you get your fruits and vegetables
grains.
That's what they tell you when you're
pregnant.
But for most people I don't think so
grain really.
We've been eating grain for what like
maybe twenty thousand years in some
areas.
More like 10000 years and in some areas
2000 years and if you're Native American
like 200 years haven't been eating grain
for very long Why do people suddenly
think they can digest that just because
we're people
so you don't believe Rice.
Rice is a green rice I think is a lot
less inflammatory than some grains like
the gluten grains are obviously a lot
harder on people.
And even I tolerated Rice kind of for a
while.
But yeah I don't think grains feed a lot
of people.
And so that's why the agricultural error
came around now.
We can feed tons of people which doesn't
make people thrive and I don't think
it's good for their god.
I don't think that's surprising
considering we haven't been eating it
long enough to evolve with it.
But other than grain what are the issues
you have with what we would call like a
paleo diet or a healthy diet.
So with vegetables and do you think
there's an issue eating vegetables.
I think it really depends on the person.
I think that this beef salt and water
diet is a really good elimination diet.
And if you're seriously suffering and
you have nothing to lose you can give it
a go suffer through the transition
period and then try and once you feel OK
try and reintroduce foods and see where
you stand.
What about vitamin supplementation
though and why wouldn't you tell people
what move why wouldn't you recommend
multivitamins or a multivitamin pack
that covers all your basics.
I say if you want if you're really
concerned about vitamins get vitamin
infusions I react to multi vitamins so
the fillers there aren't any pure
vitamins you can take unless you take
them in powder form so you can get
vitamin C powder potassium powder but
it's hard to get the other vitamins in
powder form and I react to everything.
So so even the filler often caps
I probably wouldn't react to pure
gelatin capsules but like filler what
kind of filler micro appears to lean
cellulose isn't a lot of them.
Why do they put that stuff in there.
Well a lot of them is to bind it
together you know if it's like a tablet
then most of that is like powdery stuff
that isn't the actual vitamin.
What about capsules.
I don't know.
I haven't tested it out like buy because
it's this month long reaction I pretty
much just say get rid of all the
variables you can get rid of and start
from scratch and then you can see if if
things are bothering you if you're
worried about vitamins get infusions.
Right.
But what I was saying is that you were
talking about these binders do they
exist in capsules as well.
Yeah you have to check the ingredients.
There are just it's very hard to get
vitamins that are pure unless they're in
powdered form or either by infusion.
I couldn't find a multivitamin I could
take a lot of the vitamin KS derived
from soy so I'll react to that amount of
soy.
Mm hmm.
Wow.
So infusions you're talking about.
Yeah and I did those though I did that
during my pregnancy because just in case
I don't react to that at all is fine I
didn't find I didn't see a benefit.
It didn't make me feel any better.
How do you react to fish oil not well
but it was hard to tell because I was
reacting to other things at the same
time so I don't I don't eat chicken
anymore and I don't eat fish anymore
because it doesn't make me feel as good
as beef
but it doesn't give you a bad reaction.
Not like soy or grains.
But what if someone took it to a
restaurant and lobster was on the menu.
You would need a lobster.
No.
Wow.
No dessert.
No but the thing is the cravings go away
after you transition over so I don't
even care how has gone
three times usually.
If I'm doing more I eat more.
Otherwise I'm eating about two and a
half pounds a day.
If they're fat fatter then I'll eat
less.
To just sort of walking beef
catastrophe.
Yeah.
It's great though.
It's um it's amazing.
And I drink like sparkling water which I
love Perry excites me.
So just Perrier and beef and salt.
That's a
now.
What do you think about people that say
that this idea might work in the short
term in the short term but in the long
term it's not sustainable.
I don't even know what kind of response
to have to that like
what I was doing.
For example on vegan diets right.
With diets as they start off they feel
great.
They're like Oh my God this is the diet
for me this is amazing.
And over time their body starts reacting
to the lack of nutrients lack of
cholesterol lack of saturated fat and it
doesn't doesn't in different bodies.
I mean obviously some people have no
problem with it but some people have
like legitimate like Chris Crestor is a
perfect example.
He started out with a macrobiotic vegan
diet and had real serious reactions to
it over time.
Yeah started out doing well.
And then over time started to break his
body down.
How long did it take.
I forget but when he started
reintroducing meat back into his diet he
had a massive ramp up.
You know it's ramp up like he got worse
health health while Oh yeah fantastic.
Yeah.
And suddenly everything started kicking
in again.
Yeah yeah.
So I'm not worried about it like I was
so sick before this and now I'm better.
What I was concerned I was going to die
in the long run before and now I'm
feeling good.
I don't see why I would just randomly
get sick suddenly I'm getting my
vitamins tested because people are
curious but I I don't have any symptoms.
And who is this besides this woman.
Have you been in contact with this woman
that's been doing this for nine years.
Not personally no but where were you.
Somewhere in the States.
Mm hmm.
And so Sean Baker is probably the
loudest proponent and one of the most
vocal and more most public and he's been
doing it I believe two years
my friend Chris Bell's been doing it for
a while as well.
I think he's less than a year but he
apples.
He loves apples.
I had a hard time giving up apples.
Let's find Sara.
Seriously it's because I limited I went
down on all my sugar and then I was
eating hoards of apples and that was my
sugar right.
And that was hard to kick in apples.
Somehow or another give you low back
pain among other things.
But yeah.
Huh.
It comes along with a depression and
arthritis
the whole thing is a really interesting
conversation because there's so much
going on with it.
It's and it's not an objective
conversation for the most part.
Like many people that get into this they
get into this it's very charged it's
charged almost politically it's charged
ideologically it's charged whether it's
ethically and morally it's it's charged
where people are very skeptical.
Also they have this diet that they
believe in that they've been following.
And so anything that's contrary to that
they reject.
Yeah well I used to be like people when
I was really sick.
People come up and go Well have you
looked at your diet.
It's like what you like me mean disorder
I'm dying have I like what stop eating
sugar and all my problems will go away
like thanks.
So I've been on the other end of the
spectrum and I used to get mad when
people said but it was like
condescending right.
If you'd like tried.
Have you tried exercising have you
looked at your diet.
No it's like I'm dying.
And then I thought maybe now that I look
back on it.
How crazy is it then.
It wasn't even a conversation 10 years
ago right.
Yeah like ten years ago.
You ever hear this.
No.
That's what's so weird like the cutting
the sugar out and cutting the carbs out.
This is so new it's so new and this like
meat diets really now.
And but by the way but when I say new I
mean in terms of like being popular
really popular like yeah or something
people have heard us.
Yeah it's it's it's really interesting.
It's and when I see your dad and how
healthy he is and how he looks so he
again looks younger it looks thinner.
Like it's like it's like he's all sucked
in.
Yeah looks like yeah.
Looks healthy.
I know he looks like a different person
than the person I knew.
And I look like a different person than
the person I knew.
My face looks different in a good way.
Yeah.
Well I think there's something definite
definitely healthy about getting a lot
of fat.
Yeah.
And this is something that I think we've
ignored with our obsession with carbs
and one of the things that is a giant
benefit for people that cut the carbs
out is the way you you feel about food.
Like you don't get these massive craving
my God.
Yeah yeah.
I used to so when I used to go to eat I
was starving all the time I just felt
like I was starving and I'd eat and then
I would feel so full.
And it turns out it was bloating right.
But I know that I just feel so full that
I would literally have to ask people to
take my plate away or I would keep
eating because I was starving but
stuffed.
And that was just my state all the time.
You know it's fucked up no matter how
full I am.
If you put a plate of french fries with
salt and in front of me I will go after
those bitches.
I can't help myself.
This I'll eat one Mike is so good.
And then with some ketchup like fat
steak fries that are like kind of well
done ish with some salt them and ketchup
there's just something about that trick
that biological trick that those goddamn
potatoes play on you.
Yeah that's.
Yeah.
It's kind of addictive but so addictive.
I know.
And it turns out that even like the
amount of salad I was eating lettuce was
still kind of addictive because I had
like lettuce cravings lettuce cravings.
Yeah I mean not like my apple cravings.
Not like my sugar cravings but they were
that they were there.
So when you just eat only me your body
takes that meat in through process of
glucose Genesis converts it to glucose
right.
Yeah.
So I'm.
I haven't been out of ketosis and I'm
always in ketosis but my glucose is
normal that's what's weird.
The fact that you're always in ketosis
because most people think that if you
eat try a protein.
Yeah but that's the thing is if you like
convert what I'm eating to the fat ratio
80 percent of my calories or I'm getting
from fat.
Are you doing this on an app or
something.
I'm mostly typing in the cuts and then I
can kind of add in how much tallow I'm
adding to lean ground beef.
How much time do you how do you do about
tablespoon or I do it.
Yeah I do it kind of by tablespoon I
just scoop it in.
But if I if I was measuring it I'd like
four five.
Who do you heat the tallow up first and
then cook the beef and do it or do you
kind of like some older guy just mix
everything together.
It's way more satisfying though because
eating lean ground beef just isn't good.
It gets drier dry ground elk is even
worse.
Wow.
It's delicious but it's so sinewy you
know.
But when I mix it with butter and stuff
like that.
Yeah.
So I'm just mixing a little.
It's great.
All.
It's going on my voice.
So when you're you're looking at the
future and you know you're saying OK
this is going well this is you know much
better than anything I've ever done
before.
I feel so much better.
Do you feel like this is the way you're
going to eat for the rest of your life.
Yeah.
Do you think it's sustainable.
Yeah
oh.
I'm not arguing against it.
I'm just I'm wondering sustainable in
what way nutritionally.
Oh my God.
Yeah I think so.
I'll keep getting my vitamins tested.
But this book that I've been reading
about this guy lived with anyway.
That's what they ate.
They were healthy.
They don't have teeth that fell out like
they weren't sick like were sick.
The annuals are the people that went up
there anyways.
Yeah but the annuals didn't evolve that
way.
I mean if you stop and think about it I
mean but didn't we evolve that way too.
I don't know.
I mean we can't say we changed like
10000 years ago in order to eat grain.
Looks like we've evolved to hunt.
Kinda yeah.
Yeah I mean but different people that
grew up in different areas of the world.
I think they have.
I mean isn't it been proven that there's
different nutritional requirements that
different people have if you're you grew
up in different areas.
I don't think so.
No I haven't read that.
No
what does that.
That diet that people.
There's there's like some.
Some diet that they they try to
was based on bloodwork.
Oh the blood type diet.
Yeah.
The idea is that different people that
have different blood types that they're
coming from different parts of the
world.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't really look well man.
So my diet with a summary of your guide
to zero about diets.
I'm.
I know Dad told me like he went over and
he said I don't think I can eat fish.
I think fish is giving me a flare up and
my response was like well that's not
possible.
Feel like all I'm eating is meat and I
still have the same response.
And then I told you I don't eat chicken.
Well when I switched over.
Chicken started to make me not feel
good.
When I was eating it.
What about ostrich.
I haven't tried ostrich.
I've just given up on birds ruminant
animals seem fine.
I tried bison bison was fine bison.
What do what do you call it bison.
Is that a Canadian.
I'm just gonna go with that's a Canadian
obviously bison.
By God I hope it's the Canadians.
Well dad says it's his fault.
The ostrich is interesting because it's
red.
It's a bird but it's a red meat.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
They have ostrich burgers at FUD
records.
You can get an ostrich burger.
The fucking good that ribeye the sky
bird.
I haven't had that.
That's a Sandhill Crane.
Yeah Sandhill Crane is a really die guy.
That's what they call him.
They stay there they they hunt them and
they cook it.
It's a really delicious lean but like
soft juicy tender red meat.
Huh.
Yeah well you got get a photo of it.
Yeah look at that.
That's what looks like what.
Yep.
Sandhill Crane.
Wild Canada Goose.
Where.
I don't think we're allowed to eat that
in Canada.
Well some some.
You're not allowed to eat some migrating
geese right but Sandhill Crane.
I bet you could eat.
Wow.
Wow I wonder.
I have some buddies that hunted those in
Texas and they said they were fantastic.
So that's some of the best meat they've
ever eaten in their life.
What if you could eat that but I
wouldn't want you to eat it then get
fucking hives and shit.
Yeah.
Now I may find a job for a mine for five
weeks.
Yeah.
Diarrhea.
Everything all over again.
Yeah.
So your plan is just sparkling water and
steak forever.
Yeah and I mean it could be more like I
could be surviving off of eggplant.
Could be worse.
Oh yeah.
I enjoy everything I read all the time.
Yeah right.
I love it and I don't get bored.
I thought if there's one thing I have to
eat forever I hope it's steak because
I'm not gonna get bored of steak.
And like I said the first month was kind
of rough but then the cravings go away
and now it's like every meal and like
mom stay you get hate from vegan people.
Not really.
I don't think I'm as inflammatory as
some people because I can understand.
I mean if you're Italy.
Ideology.
Ideologically possessed.
That's different.
But if you go on a vegan diet you cut
out processed foods you get rid of
dairy.
Dairy was a huge trigger for me and you
feel better than I can understand why
you'd be going around saying the vegan
diet is the way to eat right.
So I can can I can understand where
those people are coming from.
If you're ideologically possessed and
you're saying well it's the environment
all this stuff I don't really care.
So no I don't get it.
I've got like a couple of emails about
me spreading lies like well I just don't
I don't really don't care.
There's a lot of loonies out there.
What a loony people but that is the
issue with the the the vegan diet is
that it carries with it a moral high
ground.
Yeah but other diet.
So yeah.
That's too bad.
That part sucks.
The people trying to figure out their
health and going to that because it's
they're trying to figure something out
that's different.
Like the whole moral thing like just let
it go.
Well listen I think this is very
interesting stuff.
You know I don't have your health issues
and I think very few people do.
But obviously for you it's it's made
some massive impact at home and for your
father as well.
I mean it's really
it's very very interesting.
And like I said my friend lives in San
Diego.
No problems.
I mean he's he's loving it.
I know several other people that have
jumped on board as well too and they're
seeing big benefits from them.
I mean it's almost enough to make me
want to try it but you should try.
Well the problem doesn't take long.
But I I have hundreds of pounds of wild
game meat.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
But I have to eat it with fat and have
to figure out a way to get fat into it.
You can order towel here.
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
This order towel.
It's on it like I haven't I've talked to
people like programmers in Silicon
Valley who've Skype me and they're
healthy and they just want to be more
productive and the cognitive benefits it
takes like six weeks and it's worth just
seeing what it's like but they get that
just from the ketogenic diet.
No.
I've had people switch off of the
ketogenic.
There's there's something here there's
really something here and it's worth are
you seeing.
No I think people would see benefits if
they tried it.
Even healthy people.
What do you think those benefits are
coming from.
I don't know.
I don't know if microbiome switch or if
there's less you're just ingesting less
plant toxin or if it's a toxin.
What do you mean by the wild plants have
like naturally occurring toxins
depending on the plant to get bugs and
things to stop eating them.
That's just their defense mechanism.
So like oscillates that's a big one
lecterns like all those types of things
are inflammatory and it just seemed like
we've just found the plants that we can
tolerate as humans we found the plants
we can tolerate the easiest and don't
kill us and we eat those and we've bred
them so that they're easier to eat but
so maybe removing those from the diet
seems to help people.
But it seems like giving it a six week
try
I don't see a downside.
Again I've only I haven't seen anybody
switch back.
Really.
Mm hmm.
And I've been talking to a lot of people
on Skype over like periods of months and
I haven't seen anyone switch back
including the healthy people.
All right.
Well I'm curious this conversation's
evolving.
That's for sure.
And you know it's evolving with many
many people all across the country.
And you know when you take out the
ideological or the moral high ground
argument that vegetarians have it's it's
it's interesting to me at the very least
is interesting.
Yeah something going on.
So if people want to check out your blog
what would that be.
Well that's McKayla Peterson dot com
spell.
Am I k h a I L.A..
All right.
Peterson dot com dot com.
And is there another name for it isn't
it.
Don't eat that.
If you go to don't eat that dot is that
it.
No I don't have that somebody has bought
it or are trying to sell it back to me
for a lot fuckers.
Now these fuckers.
Thank you.
Thank you Carl.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah.
Good bye everybody.